[Music]
we started out and we thought that there
are some principles that basic things
from which all things flow and we think
that those are stated in the diversity
of Independence and they give rise to
constitutionalism and we went on to say
that the Constitution depends upon
certain broad things in its structure
and the chief of those is separation of
powers and all that really means
separation of powers is that the kinds
of powers in government are divided into
different branches and the same people
don't hold at the same time and that
means more than one person is running
the government all the time in all of
its different functions and more than
one group of people is running them and
and James Madison says that's the most
important thing about the Constitution
and it gives the Constitution its
structure how does it become possible
for us to have separation of powers what
are the grounds of that that are laid in
the Constitution what establishes the
three branches the judiciary the
legislative and the executive and by
making them distinct in a note that's
what that is what lays the ground for
that how does it come to be possible for
them to set up that system that I'm
going to turn back to you anyway to
describe to us all what I'm ready I get
to be the teacher okay see what are you
gonna say they write it all down in the
Constitution so the Constitution it
basically sets up all other facets of
the legislature judiciary executive
branches so after that we can we talk
about static from powers that they all
have and it seems like the Constitution
is sort of the fruits of those seeds
that we saw in the Declaration of
Independence where they saw God in like
these three roles like divine providence
supreme judge and the laws of nature
came down that's see okay remember our
code right
that that wasn't good enough but it was
on the way so if you take that what you
actually was not responsive to my
question and that we're on the way to
the answer I'm looking for and the
question is so so you say it's like the
fruit of a seed that's planted in the
Declaration and what you say Tim is God
has explained it's the three branches
you need to elaborate that because the
seed is a little more direct than that
in my argument well at the time the king
was trying to execute all three branches
of government in their list of and
justices it was explaining how this has
led to basically a long history of
tyranny and basically the three branches
that they establish in the Constitution
are the three areas that the king at the
time was trying to control all the same
time that's the statement that why this
thing is necessary and why not to do it
is bad but think about it for a minute
so let me ask you I said this explicitly
several times yesterday and I know you
weren't listening to me because you were
busy being photographed but but today
we're gonna have to think right today we
got up in the morning thing we're gonna
work all right now in the Federalist
Papers Madison makes the point now
Hamilton makes the point that the
judiciary is the least dangerous branch
something that might have changed and
the House of Representatives is actually
the most dangerous branch why what is
that about from your close reading of
the Federalist well I don't let to call
you we're gonna call you spider-man
so my spidey senses tell me so in terms
of in relation to the public to the
people we directly vote for that the
representatives and the House
representatives those are the people
that are basically closest to our
thoughts and now we're getting somewhere
Emily's twitching what do you think
well I was thinking in relation to your
first question as well as your second
question on the House of Representatives
not only is it directly connected to the
people but it has the power of the purse
and therefore makes it the most
dangerous but the fact that it's
connected back to the people sort of
leads back to the Constitutional
Convention itself and the fact that we
had to go through the war in the
Articles of Confederation and actually
create a constitution based in or based
in the people and there is an actual
physical process sovereign the people
won because they have the vote of
authority for what can be done why do
they have that because they all men are
created equal so yeah the seed all men
are created equal it then follows that
no one may be governed except by their
you're gonna have unanimous consent to
form the Republic and then you're gonna
have majority rule to decide things so
we've entered a realm right there's a
universe this is like a planet this is
one of the ways to do it turns out it's
the best way right they're even claiming
it's the only really good way but once
you've done that think now what follows
right we talked about what a country is
and why we have them it's rooted in this
gift of speech that we have right we
always have them we're always going to
have laws and the laws are always built
on some agreement what we called
yesterday the final cause of the nation
and the final cause of our nation makes
the people strong whereas the final
cause of an absolute monarchy or any
strong monarchy makes the eldest son of
the oldest and strongest family powerful
so if the sovereign is the strongest
thing then the sovereign is also the
most dangerous thing it's the thing that
can get everything out of balance get
all power unto itself so
all men are created equal therefore they
may be governed only with their consent
therefore the majority will be sovereign
and therefore the majority will be the
most dangerous thing right that they be
sovereign necessary that they be
sovereign but dangerous so you got that
we're living on that planet right we're
not on Jupiter where the gods pick the
sovereign and we're not on Mars where
the Warriors pick that's actually better
than I intended to be when I started
human beings all are created equal each
of us consent the majority will rule so
now after that the $64,000 question is
we know who the sovereign is how's the
sovereign going to operate in relation
to the government how we going to set
that up and how do they answer that
question where do they put the sovereign
in the garden like Christian they put it
as the voter of people who then become
ones Republic and that means and this is
the thing that Madison says in the 63rd
Federalists which we read yesterday that
Madison says is unique nobody ever
thought of this one before we're gonna
put the sovereign outside and that means
they can't get out of hand harder for
them to get it they're in control harder
for them to become oppressive of others
the first check the Constitution is a
set of checks and balances which Madison
argues is written in the nature of
things and if you think about it we've
been saying that two-year-olds or so
start talking in dogs don't right and
that's just a fact that's how it is well
this is a fact how it is the same way
you know if you give somebody absolute
power over you and that
person is any other living person I've
ever met except my wife and my closest
friends they're likely to abuse that
power right
and of course marriages and friendships
operate on a small scale politics
operates among people who don't know
each other very well and they're people
and they have needs and they see the
world through their own eyes and not
through everybody's eyes they're not
divine beings even if they're divine
like you see so keep them out but let
them vote now we're in an amazing
situation because all the power is out
here and it can be delegated in a
variety of ways into a variety of people
to do a variety of kinds of tasks and
the delegation can even happen at
different times our powers are separated
and eat and you couldn't do that except
that all the sovereignty is outside and
then given in in this way and Madison
says that because of this and because of
other things we can protect this
separation separation of powers by the
way is the biggest single protection in
the Constitution isn't it because the
structure of the Constitution it's
organized in articles right and the
first article is about a branch and the
second article is about another branch
and the third article about a third
branch and the fourth article is about a
different mostly about a different level
of government right so the people are
through this Constitution delegating
authority to a government and they're
doing it in these separate articles to
indicate these separate branches and
then even before that the right of the
people to consent and the inability of
the people actually to operate the
government are themselves divisions of
power
you